hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
the game where i play
sorry and i say to myself
and i'm dead
[Music]
no no
yeah i know this area very well
i will not be swayed by such cheap jump
scares speak up if you'd like to murder
me
who doesn't speak up shut up we'll close
the door that'd be a good idea
i'm hungry can i split thirsty me up i
am
[Music]
my god apparently also i'm recording
this
my face is a camera everything's fine
just me and
help me a little late for that but if
you need a hand
i can give you one
into a region they call gasper zone
sounds like a mario level but okay is
gasper's zone real
who am i asking this who am i asking
this to you did what you could
i don't think i did anything and i
sure plop oh
and now a musical with markiplier
[Laughter]
whoa i love the flesh it's supple
delights
it sets my heart of lame
whoa loving flesh is my
favorite thing our first date
ended no seconds for me
one and done they call me the one
pump jumped by me
this should probably be fine hey no i'm
not in that room what are you talking
about
what do you mean
[Music]
no no no no no no hey hi
oh hey i'm handsome how are you oh
[Music]
okay cool thank you please don't turn
around i'm about to solve a puzzle
there that sounds strong come on you
son of a [ __ ] i told you not to
turn around oh x
x marks the spot oh oh my god
none of that thank you very much that's
rude that's very
high
oh i see
i see i see
it is like p
t scary ball hello
okay well that's you gonna do that again
oh yeah you are gonna do that again okay
what
what [ __ ] what the [ __ ] spooky
very spooky almost this spooky
[Music]
what the what the hell where'd you come
with me
once you start to get the mechanics it's
a little easy to get away from her
but oh no not here
what the indeed hey
all right cool i got nothing to say
about this in my vlog
you're a butthole
[Music]
and now a lullaby with markiplier
go to sleep go to
sleep please don't kill
me in the night
go to sleep please go to sleep
and for the love of god
blink i don't have lights
hey you are you close are you are you
close
yeah what are you doing
can i get that gun what if i just
oh good
you [ __ ] what the heck was that you
dick
do not turn around oh god should i turn
around guys leave a like if i should
turn around
okay well glad that's gone forever
[Music]
you